la refonte du musée girodet aussi bien à
l'intérieur qu'à l'extérieur va presque
doubler la surface de l'édifice à
l'avant une verrière de 250 m² à
l'arrière une extension sur trois étages
il y aura aussi la création de salles
pour les expositions temporaires
ça évite de fermer le musée quand on
s'installe et ça nous permet de recevoir
des collections importantes avec des
conditions de conservation et de
sécurité qui peuvent être adaptés aux
prêts qui sont faits sur les grands
musées nationaux quand il pointe et
interactions quand ils prêtent des
oeuvres il nous impose ses conditions
l'enveloppent de cette refonte 5 million
deux cent mille euros hors taxes et pour
tenir le budget il a fallu changer de
maître d'oeuvre en cours de route car
30% trop cher alors le nouvel architecte
a dû trouver des solutions il a écrit
des cahiers des charges simplifié qui
ont permis aux entreprises de mieux
comprendre ce qu'on leur demandait une
entreprise quand elle ne comprend pas
très bien ce qu'on lui demande elle
libre j'ai pas bien compris je mettront
pour faire plus et est du coup du coup
les prix montent quand elle a bien
compris elle va au plus près et elle
prévoit exactement ce qu'on lui demande
le prix baissent la fin des travaux
c'est juin 2016 ensuite il faudra
rapatrier les collections des centaines
d'oeuvres stockés dans les bâtiments de
l'agglomération il s'agit d'une ancienne
banque avec une salle des coffres
sécurisés
encore un choix économique un
garde-meubles aurait coûté plus d'un
million d'euros là ça coûte rien puisque
les assurances sont les mêmes que pour
le musée
ce qu'on fait d'habitude et que ce sont
nos locaux donc on s'est privé de salle
de réunion voilà mais on a sécurisé un
espace correctement aussi bien qu'au
musée peut être même mieux
le musée de france devrait ouvrir dans
un an après plus de quatre heures de
fermeture on souhaite justement que ce
soit abordable pour tout le monde que
des personnes qui n'ont pas l'habitude
justement de venir au musée est leur
entrée et puissent venir facilement
qu'ils osent franchir la porte des
musiques et bonne nouvelle le ticket
d'entrée qui coûtait 3 euros ne devrait
pas augmenter